why didn't the skeleton play cricket
because his heart wasn't in it now let's
begin this cue pisode with the situation
a person is experiencing cold sweat
he's also experiencing an aching
sensation in his chest or arms that's
spreading to his neck and jaw with the
symptoms given here can you guess what's
the person suffering from no prizes for
guessing he's suffering from a cardiac
arrest
Oh is he suffering from a heart attack
does it matter both mean the same don't
they well time to find out the term
cardiac arrest and heart attack are
often used interchangeably but the
startling fact is that these two are two
different conditions you heard me right
they are different let's unravel the
difference in this Q pisode we already
know that our heart muscles require
constant supply of oxygen rich blood for
the nourishment and proper functioning
and this job is meticulously done by
coronary arteries but the problem occurs
when you have a coronary artery disease
it's the condition where the arteries
become narrow and the blood is not able
to flow as it should and what could be
the reason for this one of the reasons
could be hardening or clogging of the
arteries this could be majorly because
of the build-up of cholesterol and fatty
deposits on the inner walls of the
arteries these restrict the blood flow
to the heart by physically clogging the
artery due to the clogging the blood
supply will be inadequate without
adequate blood supply the heart becomes
starved of oxygen and subsequently will
fall short of vital nutrients which is
needed by it for working efficiently
and the part that's devoid of oxygen
rich blood starts to die thus can result
in chest pain which is one of the
symptoms of heart attack identifying the
symptoms and getting it treated can save
the life of a person if not then it can
even lead to a fatal attack now let me
tell you a fact here during an attack
usually the heart does not stop beating
this wasn't brief about heart attack and
one of the major reasons that causes it
okay now we note that in heart attack
it's usually a particular region of the
heart that becomes non-functional but
the heart does not stop beating so is it
even possible for the heart to stop
beating all of a sudden yes it's
possible in medical terms this condition
is called cardiac arrest let's
understand more about it a human heart
is triggered to beat with regular
electrical pulses but if these
electrical pulses become erratic it
results in irregular heartbeats this
condition in medical term is called
arrhythmia this will result in the
disrupted pumping of the heart as a
consequence the heart is unable to pump
blood to the vital organs like the
brains lungs and so on in a few seconds
the patient loses consciousness and has
no pulse the patient almost stops
breathing or is only gasping the patient
may even die if not administered with
proper treatment scary right it's
actually more scarier as sometimes it
occurs all of a sudden without any
warning unlike that of a heart attack
which usually shows symptoms now
understanding cardiac arrest and heart
attack could make all the difference
when it comes to helping someone
experiencing such an event
in this episode we try to make you
understand the difference between heart
attack and cardiac arrest we know the
reasons for having heart attack now the
question is what are the probable causes
of cardiac arrest that is why would the
heart suddenly start beating irregularly
well this is your cue box to explore let
us know your findings in the comment
section below